welcome to architecting startups with
google cloud a series where we showcase
the latest and greatest startups and how
they are building and deploying their
production-ready workloads with gcp i'm
felipo madella and i lead one of the
customer engineering teams here at
google and today i have the privilege of
welcoming hannes hapke he leads the
machine learning work at digits and
digits mission is to revolutionize how
business owners and accountants think
and use and interact with their
financial business transactions so
welcome planets to the show and thanks
once more for joining it's great to be
here i'm thrilled to share how digit is
using google cloud to build its core
products thank you for having me
no i'm sorry it's our pleasure so can
you cover a little bit what digit does
and what's the story behind it
digits is on a mission to build the next
generation of finance tools by
leveraging our proprietary model the
goal of our living model is to empower
accountants and business owners with
insights in real time
instead of waiting until an accountant
reviewed the books digits provides
answers in seconds and we use a number
of machine learning models under the
cover to make that possible okay so to
start can you share what's the
experience of a user when they log in on
your platform what do they see uh what
are the main features that you offer
design and usability is paramount at
digits at the same time machine learning
is central to the mission of digits from
the moment digits ingest a banking
transaction until a user sees the
transactions a few moments later in the
dashboard
a number of machine learning models have
processed the transaction
for example we extract key information
from the transaction
to match the
the exact transaction with related
historical transactions when a business
owners logs into digits they experience
a holistic view of their business
each transaction is annotated with
information about the related entities
which allows us to provide rich
statistics and sophisticated search
experiences
when accountants use digits they can
generate in-depth reports
for their clients which go way beyond
the typical pdfs at the same time digits
is cross-checking transactions against
historical patterns to alert accountants
about potential mistakes
so it's very cool
on your website it says you're you're
bringing accountants from the future
so
machine learning
looks like it's the foundational piece
behind your platform
so let's of course focus on that can you
talk a little bit about the
the overall machine learning workflow
and like the life cycle in general that
you approach
within digits
our machine learning projects consist
out of two major phases phase one is the
experimentation phase our data
scientists and machine learning
engineers can use any open source tool
they like
they could be pytorch tensorflow jacks
scikit-learn whatever gives them the
biggest speed boost to prove that a
machine learning model can solve a
business problem once we get to the
proof of concept stage and we have
proven that a machine learning model can
solve that business problem then we take
that model and turn that into a
production machine learning workflow
this is what we do in phase two
phase two consists out of three
components
number one would be creating a machine
learning pipeline this allows us to
reproduce a machine learning model at
any given point in time by anybody on
the team without
as little context as needed
here we're using vertex pipelines
tensorflow extended and other tools to
standardize our production of the
machine learning models
once the pipeline completes the
production of those machine learning
models they get registered with a
registry and from there we have a number
of actions they consume those machine
learning models one action could be a
batch process we use we use vertex
batch prediction processes to spin up
resources
predict a number of
data sets for us and then return the
results the second consumer would be
online endpoints which consume the
models load them into a microservice and
then downstream processes can consume
those models major consumers of our
machine learning models are dataflow
jobs in gcp
thank you for the overview of this life
cycle and as we talked about it uh it's
historically like if you're an ml
engineer and you're going from the
experimentation phase all the way to
your employment
you know to production it's like
historically it's been a challenge to
make it at least loosely coupled and i
see you having
a great experience
with like tfx and vertex ai in general
so let's double click on the ml
pipelining face can you just
go over a little bit how you set that up
currently yeah so when we have a proof
of concept and we want to turn this into
a production model we use tfx to express
the pipelines so a pipeline would ingest
data from various sources that could be
a gcs path that could be a bigquery
dataset or a feature store we then
pre-process the data to whatever the
model needs to train so we would i don't
know
generate tokens out of unstructured text
or standardize some values then we scale
it out that we scale out the training
part
with vertex training jobs and that
allows us to use different hardware
types for whatever their model needs
once the model is produced
we then push it back to various data
flow jobs running on tfx or running with
tfx to analyze the model and compare it
to the last produced models
and then once everything is confirmed to
be an improvement we registered the
model through the pipelines with the
metadata store and the model registry
thank you
and if we go now to talk about vertex ai
which is google cloud's end-to-end
integration
uh platform for data in ml and ai in
general
and we know that ml ops
is it's again another challenging aspect
right when you go from a specific domain
of knowledge which is data science
machine learning artificial intelligence
and then you're moving now to
infrastructure
uh certainly requires something more
like more skills or a bigger team so
how has vertex ai taking care of your of
your operations today can you go a
little bit over like your previous
experience and your experience now you
can run tfx pipelines
on a number of orchestrators they can
run on apache beam they can run on
apache airflow
and kubeflow pipelines in a kubernetes
environment and we have previously
maintained our own cluster and run our
pipelines in that setup but
in such an configuration we always had
to provision the hardware so for example
if we wanted to
train on a newer gpu then we would have
to provision this into our own
kubernetes cluster and uh
that required a lot of overhead on the
team
so by moving
to vertex pipelines we got the chance to
just use a managed service to get access
to all the hardware and at the same time
it removed the constraints so we could
basically we can scale all pipelines and
retrain all models at the same time
something which we couldn't have done in
our own cluster previously
well it's really great to hear i know
also that amongst the features of vertex
ai you been talking about
the vertex
metadata
and
i want can you share a little bit more
about it how does that help you and i
know you you kind of consider like a
underrated uh feature
right um i truly think that the metadata
store is an is an underrated tool within
the vertex portfolio um it sort of lives
alongside those pipelines um but it is
basically what i consider it as an
insurance policy for machine learning
engineers so every time we run a
pipeline
the components of all the pipelines are
talking to the metadata store every time
they start operating and when they
complete the operation so we for
every data set every model or every
analysis we create or touch we get a
record in our metadata store
and there will be moments when
the question will come up why did the
model produce a prediction in a certain
way and it's not easily explainable in
that moment we go back to the metadata
store to reproduce the model with the
artifacts we have we have stored in our
records system which is the metadata
store and then we can start unwind the
question and like
reproduce the model and so it doesn't
happen very often but when it happens it
is extremely useful to have the medicare
as well
thank you so we talked about
the
machine learning life cycle the
pipelines and i would like to hear more
about the deployment phase could you
expand a little
a little bit more on the specifics on
how that works within digits today
absolutely so
once we
run machine learning pipeline and the
pipeline outputs a machine learning
model
we then register the model with our
model registry in that moment
data scientist or machine learning
engineer will be contacted gets a
message that was like hey the model is
ready please validate that everything is
according to
what you had expected
the pipeline itself in our setup is
generating a number of reports we can
then study those reports and make the
decision whether we want to promote this
model or not and once we promote the
model we have
a really sweet
ci setup where we can promote those
models to vertex endpoints previously we
had hosted our own gke cluster and
within the cluster we had a node pool
just for our machine learning models but
there we felt like we were constrained
by the
the overhead we had to
provide to run those models so with
vertex endpoints
we
can now scale our machine learning
operations without the infrastructure
concerns and that
freed up the small team
heavily and we can focus more on the
machine learning side than
on the infrastructure side okay so if we
talk about then the
the endpoints like now you're consuming
your model
how's that been working for you what's
the experience like what did you why are
you choosing uh to use endpoints
so
the endpoints give us the great
opportunity to scale the operations um
we have um machine learning models they
get consumed online they get consumed on
a 247 basis and then we have a number of
batch jobs running behind the scenes
and so sometimes
everything happens at the same time
and the vertex model endpoints allow us
to scale those operations if we need
more firepower to
provide predictions fast to our clients
the endpoints scale automatically we
don't have to worry about it
we don't have the overhead of
maintaining auto scaling for our
kubernetes classes etc so this is this
was a real
win
for the machine learning ops team or the
machine learning team so that we don't
have to worry about the ops on this on
our side
okay
and
so
i always like to share
a little bit the experiences and
learnings that
that we have in these conversations i
know you've been doing this for a while
and you also have written books about it
if you if you get your experience with
digits or in general and if you were to
share any learnings and opportunities
that you think if you could go back and
and do differently or anything that for
example digits as well wants to invest
in the future as far as
uh your infrastructure or the open
source community or the the futures
within the platform itself what would
those be
i think
the investment into emo ops or ml
engineering when we talk about all the
pipelines and deployment endpoints and
metadata stores that is a large
investment
let's be honest that that took
weeks and months to set everything up
and to tie all their products together
into a really seamless workflow on our
end
but that investment
is paying off right now as we speak
because now we can reproduce those
models
we have
single points where everybody on the
team finds information around machine
learning models um we can scale models
in depending on the demands so this is
it
took it was a
quite the engineering effort to put this
all together um but it was greatly
assisted by all the different vertex
products and so
we see
um this investment now paying off with
like faster times to market for machine
learning models and fewer concerns
around all the infrastructure and
all the deployment issues we had
previously at the same time
we also learned
that machine learning models
they're very closely coupled to the
design and vice versa
so we work very closely together with
our
design teams um and sometimes the
designers have questions for us it's
like hey we have an online forum can we
predict some things
to make this form more seamless
and at the same time sometimes we have
questions for the designers and say like
hey we have a machine learning model
here we would like to
get a feedback loop into the product and
how can we design this so that is the
experience for the customers is very
seamless
and i feel like sometimes
machine learning projects fail because
the design phase is not considered and
that was one of the major learnings that
the close relationship with the design
team
they are closely coupled to all the
machine learning projects they're part
of the team or everybody's part of that
team
and they're not like siloed into
two
different entities
i i actually love those insights and the
fact that you mentioned it's really
overlooked the design part of the
machine learning life cycle and thinking
about it right so many ways our data or
like our models can just be skewed uh in
in kind of influence a lot on the output
just because the way we're communicating
with the users on the front end and it's
not uh
in line with the actually
the actual purpose
of the
of
the machine learning goal itself so
that's super insightful and again we're
getting to the end of our chat thank you
so much for for joining us here if
people want to hear more about digits
how where they should go they can go to
digits.ml for ml related stories or
check out digits.com to learn more about
digits in general thank you so much
honest for the conversation today once
more
we just heard how
digits using gcp specifically vertex ai
to build their ml solutions and scale
their ml pipelines
if you enjoyed this conversation please
make sure that you hit the like button
and subscribe so you can hear more
[Music]
you